i am playing very aggressively with
white
and very solidly with black now that
distinction isn't that meaningful
still because most games i'm winning
basically in the opening
um but when i reach right around a
thousand or eleven hundred i think the
the distinction is going to be more
meaningful
um and what that means is we're playing
a lot of gambits with white we're
continuing to attempt to play the danish
again but nobody's actually taking the
pawns yet
with black we're playing very solid
openings queens again with decline carl
khan
we're going to incorporate the french
openings that emphasize conceptual
understanding closed positions
pawn structure stuff that you know
people kind of shy away from because
it's either in my opinion poorly
explained or
it's often presented in such a way as to
make it
seem like it's inaccessible to the
average chess player
which it's absolutely not and that's a
ridiculous presupposition so
we're trying to cover a lot of ground
here now
because these are 10 minute games i'm
explaining more stuff during the game
itself
and the post mortems are taking us less
time that's just by design
let's go ahead and seek a 10 minute game
we're playing with the black pieces
against mustafa or 96 and speaking of
the karo khan that is like the og
solid opening c6
now most people at this level don't
really know what to do against the karo
khan some
have never seen this move before let's
see how he responds and bishop c4 is a
pretty common reaction okay queen h5 so
that's
another common reaction for those who
have never really seen the karo khan
although i haven't particularly seen
that one before so how should we respond
to this
how should we respond to this and
there's many ways to do it i mean we can
go
d5 we don't have to react to this at all
but if we were to react to it my
solid idea is to play knight f6 and just
get that queen out of there okay queen
e2
and now we can continue with our
actually knight f6 maybe it may have
been inaccurate because he has e5 it's
funny because
knight f6 may have been a little bit
impulsive
um okay he doesn't do it though it
doesn't really matter so we take with
the c pawn
again we already have an amazing
position we have a knight developed we
have the center and he's moved his queen
three times now that's pretty ridiculous
so we talked about thank you coach grant
we talked about
um this the sort of the correct um
ratio of pawn moves to peace development
moves here right
and we can either play e5 here in this
position or we can develop the other
knight
um in the solid part of the speed run
i.e in the black games i'm really
emphasizing
adherence to principles so as much as i
would like to control the center
let's focus instead on developing our
pieces because that's always going to be
the most important it's a lot more
important to develop the pieces properly
and to control a little bit more of the
center
and speaking of develop developing the
pieces properly
as i explained earlier today this is not
a pin that we are afraid of
because this pawn is very faithfully
defending that we don't need to play a6
we don't need to play bishop d7 here and
consign the bishop to a very passive
existence instead where can we put this
bishop
can we put this bishop yeah so we can
still play e5 but i'm
deliberately refraining from this yeah
so f5 is possible
but why not g4 i like bishop g4 guys
because this attacks the queen
and great so now we induced f3 now we
can step back to f5
and this is a huge weakness that is even
more amplified by the fact oh god
by the fact that he's not developing any
of his pieces all right great
come at me go h4 the more weaknesses he
makes the better
all right so
where should we go with the knight this
is an interesting question
where should we go with the knight um
because and there's more than one
correct answer here there's really
there's really several ways to think
about it but i
want to violate a rule that says which
that says knights on the rim are grim
all right
so knight h5 is what i really like here
right
because this is the frankfurt airport
analogy
this is the frankfurt airport analogy
um because the knight on h5 may seem to
be ugly
but it's aiming for this very juicy
square on f4 it's putting pressure on it
now you might look at this and say wait
a second
white can play knight e2 and defend the
square on f4 right
and we're not getting to f4 but this
plays into the concept
of putting pressure on something versus
occupying it right
putting pressure on something can be
very valuable
even if you're not immediately going to
put a piece on that square
because essentially you're creating a
situation where white now has to keep a
piece
um as a sentinel at all times
to this square and we can still put i
don't have four we can play e5 for
example but in this specific position
we should be very attentive to a
tactical property
yeah a good job track says thank you sir
being siobhan tv so we look at the
bishop it's undefended
if you guys have done puzzle battle or
puzzle rush in any kind of quantity
this is something which should be
automatic right and i'll explain putting
pressure a little bit more which is
queen a5 check that's a fork
um but the situation is complicated
because you can play knight c3 defending
the bishop
but now that runs into a pin and even
though the knight is defended by the
pawn
the pawn is the worst enemy of a pin
piece right when a pawn attacks a pin
piece
you're very often screwed and that is
the case here we're running the night
here
we're gonna be up a piece and white's
king side is in shambles so essentially
the game is over
yeah so just because i'm playing solid
chess
on the black side of the speed run
doesn't mean i'm not winning pieces when
that opportunity presents itself let's
take the knight
okay he takes we'll take he takes will
take
he has to block with the bishop
otherwise he loses the rook
now where should we drop the queen
where should we put the queen
yeah this is basically gg we should put
it on e5 with check yeah
exactly and now we should not forget to
apply the principle that i've sort of
hammered into everyone's heads
which is that we shouldn't look for
anything extraordinary in a position
like this we should simply identify
what we need to do and what i mean by
that is
we haven't completed our development
right we have a bishop that's not
developed yet we have a king that's in
the center
let's not play with fire so let's just
play e6 develop our bishop and castle
meat and potatoes plain old joe kind of
move
and yet a lot of people slip up because
they start looking for something crazy
okay bishop c3
not scary his position is full of hulls
and full of weaknesses
so we should look around the board what
are these weaknesses ah
we can take the pawn on g5 right if you
have this mentality you're looking for
white's weaknesses this is
pretty easy to spot now he gives us up
another pawn
we can take that pawn obviously
um yeah why don't we we can also give a
check on h4 it really doesn't matter
um it's completely winning position and
you know in this kind of position
anything wins as long as it's reasonable
so rook f1
okay what now you take another pawn here
but in the name of being russian school
of chess very simple
very disciplined what is very discipline
convenience retract and forcing queen
trait
yes boring chess we play very boring
chess right now okay
and then a forces queen trade he very
tilted
yeah we're going to take the queen i'm
going to try to play this very
clinically guys so we want to bring the
bishop out still right just because it's
an end game doesn't mean you
you have a license to not complete your
development but if we bring the bishop
out then he's going to take on g7
right i know that's not a big deal i
know we're up a piece and a bunch of
stuff
it doesn't matter but let's assume that
it does matter let's practice the
correct approach
we play f6 we we make the bishop fight
on granite to use my favorite phrase
now perhaps some of you are saying well
isn't this a weakening will but remember
we've traded queens
we're not even going to castle here
we're going to play king d7
we're literally going to keep the king
in the center
um and now we can get the bishop out
right
so yeah this never play f6 notion
you know i love ben but you've got to be
careful about like i know we all it's a
meme by this point but okay let's take
this one i'm just gonna take all of his
fonts
just out of principle you guys don't
mind of course
okay now okay so now a quick tactical
exercise
if you put on your sort of tactical
spectacles you will notice that
the king and the rook are on the same
diagonal
this is something you should have
noticed earlier and the bishop can
maneuver hitting this stroke to c4 yeah
good job guys
and boom and another boom
and we're up a rook he's going to give
us a check on b7
i can almost guarantee you he's going to
give us a check or he's going to resign
it's going to be one of the two
there it is um what should we do well
don't automatically move your king
remember
whenever you get a check that you don't
expect whenever you get a check that you
don't expect
um there are three ways of defending
against the check you can
capture the piece that is delivering the
check not possible here
you can move the king or you can block
the check
right repeat that mantra to yourself
when you face a check that perhaps you
didn't expect it's that way
when you're thrown off of your game you
can forget to look at this stuff okay
let's go rook bales just to
you know trade brooks he should he
should resign here i mean it's
it is just he is dead
that doesn't even okay just giving up
all of his pawns he could probably play
here too
uh but yeah let's go g5
yes hs and we won't discuss that at
length yeah i'm just gonna win this
bishop too
all right good game mustafa
yeah okay so
this was a relatively simple game the
funny thing is here
um yeah like i said knight f6 might have
been a bit of an error i think d5 was
more flexible
thank you mister because once we went d5
he can play e5 and attack the knight
and he can build something resembling a
traditional karo khan out of this
so that's just a small note
once he takes and drops his queen back i
mean
well i mean i would have just brought my
knight to b6 and then developed the
bishop to f5
just like you would in the advanced car
which i'm sure we'll have many games in
a little bit later so be patient we'll
be able to discuss this structure later
um but yeah so like here bishop g4 right
this is a move that i think some people
have an aversion to playing
because oh yeah i could have played e5
yeah
because i feel like people just find it
uncomfortable to put a piece
on any square where it makes contact
with something but like this is a simple
thing to understand right your knight is
defending the bishop
um there's no uh you know there's
nothing to it
and if white blocks with the knight then
you create a pin and then you can play
e6
and the move f3 is a huge asset for
black this is
a great thing that you have provoked
here
i i agree i think if i may attempt
to put some words in people's mouths
which i like doing
i think in addition to the contact
what's scary
is the fact that f3 attacks the bishop
right people don't want to put a piece
on a square where it can be attacked
right
am i um i think i'm being accurate here
but that's what provoking is this
concept of provoking and chess
is a very powerful one and if you look
at grandmaster games i can give you
plenty of examples
where you literally put your piece on a
square you provoke a move
and then you bring your piece back to
where it came from you literally spend
two tempi
just to provoke a tiny weakness and
this is an advanced concept at the
highest level
but at this kind of level everybody
should understand
why black benefits from this
um right burn c thank you for the prime
yeah bishop h5 is fine
i feel like the bishop is a little bit
out of play here i just feel like it's a
little bit more solid on f5 but it's
possible thank you z-cons appreciate it
um yeah hug just that's exactly right
anything on this diagonal would be great
either a bishop or a queen that's what i
was thinking of in the end
and bishop d7 is fine but slightly too
passive
i don't see like i said before i don't
really see the need
to kill the pin here it's not
particularly dangerous
right so i hope that makes sense g4
bishop g6
um yeah definitely check stock fish for
sure
okay so knight h5 should make sense uh
knight h5 should make sense guys
because i explained this move we're
aiming for f4
can you explain the weakness for us
thumbnails no not not at all of course
so there is the dictionary definition
and then there is the sort of
let's call it the working definition
right the colloquial definition what i
use
and the two are overlapping consider
like a venn diagram right
the sort of dictionary definition of a
chess of a weak square
right let's consider the concept of a
weak square
as a proxy
[Music]
for weaknesses because weaknesses don't
always aren't
only squares you can have a pawn that is
weak
it basically fits the same definition a
weak square is a square
that cannot be defended by a pawn
right so weak squares of course are
collar based like you could have y could
have a weak square bracket of a weak
square
so this f4 square is weak by definition
because white doesn't have an e pawn
that could have defended it and white's
g
pawn cannot move backward to defend it
does that make sense i
sorry i kind of butchered that a little
bit i think you get what i'm saying
so if no pawn could defend a particular
square then that square is considered
weak
the problem with this definition is that
you can nokarakon is so
probably the best opening um karokon
is probably top three now
you can look at this position and say
well by that token
this is a weakness and this is a
weakness and even well this is a
weakness and this is a weakness like
what's the meaning of this term if you
could just point to most of the squares
your opponent's position and say that
they're weak and that's where
the sort of qualification comes in right
because not all weak squares are
meaningful
the weak squares that are most
meaningful the ones that you
a have some sort of potential to occupy
with your pieces
and b ones which if you do occupy with
your pieces actually give you some sort
of benefit right
so that's essentially what a weak square
is
that's a widow weaknesses and that's how
you should think of it you think of it
as
a square or a piece that's poorly
defended okay
so d3 queen a5 check and at this point
we win
the the bishop in the game is over and
ic3d4
all right guys um if i may be direct
some of you are a little bit or way too
interested in creating this ranking of
openings there's no such thing as a
ranking of openings when i said top
three
i meants it sort of more generally kara
khan is considered one of the most
it's it's a legendary on the tier list
you know
it's a on the tier list it's it's
together with a nairo
night or from the berlin as what's
currently considered to be among the
best objective openings
the closest flag can come to
guaranteeing equality even against best
play
all right so if you're a beginner you
shouldn't worry about
marginal differences in openings i don't
think hikaru said
that the karo khan was trash i'm
in fact i would be shocked if he said
that i'm sure he didn't say it
um i'm shari acaro put it in in his top
category
all right and you said it as a joke
right well because benny watts said it
um well you don't need hikaru to say or
any or me to say that's a good opening
guys
you you can do some of the research on
your own
and yeah of course he does
yeah but benny was just trash talking
the car
even he would he would perfectly approve
of the karaoke all pawns and no hope
yeah now also please
understand that there is a distinction
to be made
between think openings that are
objectively good or bad
and openings that are recommended or not
recommended for a beginner so the danish
gambit is a legendary opening
for beginners but on the grand scheme of
things
it's like a crd opening on like a magnus
carlson scale
right because why live you know white is
worse if black knows what to do
so you know it that's where that
gradation comes in
and i said that earlier today that you
should not choose openings based on
what magnus carlsen would think of them
but rather based on
how that opening helps you maximize your
learning process
as you try to get a hold of the basic
principles and apply them and get good
positions
okay um any opening that you should play
should emphasize
development you should have a tactical
component to it
that's basically all that's required and
there's plenty of options
let's continue
m color 23.
so let's hope that we finally have a
chance to play the danish gambit
and you know when people start
thinking here they generally don't take
but we'll see no oh
f6 a horrible move that is literally
one of the worst moves in this position
now we've talked about the sort of
damiano approach
uh even after knight f3 this is a bad
move
what should i do here should we give
this immediate check on h5 is that a
good a good idea
no it's not a good idea because then
black will play g6
but we first want to take on e5 and if
he takes he basically loses yeah
this is like the damiano except we
haven't even sacrificed the knight
yeah and this is takes e5 and we win the
rook this is as old as the hills
and that basically wins the game so this
is a good dry run guys as to like
how much success you could have if you
play the danish we've never actually
even played the danish
and we are already winning games like
four moves
right yeah this hurts for sure
and it's you know we can understand him
and it's we shouldn't you know laugh at
somebody for that i mean it's like
f6 is a pretty natural move i think uh
when you think about it you're defending
the pawn
but some people don't fully understand
when you're a beginner you don't fully
understand the
sort of the consequences of weakening
your king's side like that so here white
has to be precise
um and it's a very good idea to not
screw around with your queen that queen
is trapped
and in order to untrap it we should use
the fact that the queen is pinning the
bishop
the relatively elementary tactical move
bishop h6 comes to mind
this will essentially force a queen
trait some of you may be deterred
by this by the presence of queen take c4
check but then we just cover that
and here we don't actually have to take
on f8 immediately
that's not going anywhere for the time
being we can just develop our knight
first
and defend the pawn and then when the
moment is right we can take on f8
we still don't have to take on f8 we can
make another development move
what development move should we make
yeah i play chess on my phone yeah
castles well
yeah castles is fine actually i was i
was just focusing knight g4 here exists
but
it works out for us although we have to
be careful yeah knight f7
so he comes up with an ingenious idea
but now we can take on fa just we wait
until the last moment
and then we take but if you're a
beginner i wouldn't
i would take immediately here you're in
the heads of a professional so
yeah so here a good idea would be to
play f4 just advancing another pawn into
the center
all right so knight g4 clearly attacks
that that uh square on f2 we have
several ways to defend against it
one of one of which is rook d2 the other
is knight h3
between those two moves let's play rook
d2 because we don't want our knight
sitting on the rim and sort of consigned
to defending that pawn here we can chase
away black's knight with h3
this is completely winning or up a full
rook and a couple pawns
nothing to really say here other than
just develop your pieces
exercise common sense we don't even have
to play h3 yet we can go knight f3
and i always try to make this point
right this notion that when
your opponent has a piece on your side
of the board you don't need to always
rush to chase it away um you need to
understand what that piece is doing and
we will chase it away eventually
but i'm trying to illustrate that point
and now we go e5 forking the two knights
all right okay so
what should we do here what should we do
here
yeah we should take on d6 because that
gives us two pieces for a rook we are
two pieces of full two pieces up let's
complete our development and win the
game
we bring our rook into the game notice
how i'm even in the end game bringing
all of my pieces into the game
i'm not screwing around here
not always i mean the word always in
chess
is a dangerous word right and
okay he resigns and he loses hope there
yeah um that was definitely a pretty
easy game given that he played f6 if
black declines the
center game then he should play d6
that's the better way to do it
although this is far from ideal because
white can transpose to the philidor or
white can play d-e-d-e this end game
while okay for black is not great
because black has lost castling rights
here so
uh there's no need for that i mean if
you're playing black you have to
you decide to play one e5 you kind of
have to go for this that's
sort of part of the deal you know part
of the package
and nobody you know we've reached this
position i think
once and the guy played c5 nobody has
taken on c3 yet
which is a testament to the fact that if
you put some effort into choosing the
right openings particularly with white
you really are almost guaranteeing
yourself good positions in every single
game
and so that's why i fundamentally
dispute this notion that a lot of
coaches propagate that you shouldn't
spend any time on the opening
before you're like 1600. i think that's
actually ridiculous
you know for that reason you should
spend a lot of time on the opening
because even if your technique is not up
to the grandmaster's technique
just statistically if you get good
positions every game
you're going to expose yourself to
better types of positions and you're
going to win more games
it's not rocket science so i'm also not
suggesting that the danish is the only
good type of gambit it's one of many
possible lines
but it's definitely something i can
strongly recommend
all right guys so
let's um pause the stream for today we
actually went for three and a half hours
that was longer than i expected
and if there's any last questions guys
ask them now
what um questions i will take a couple
questions before we sign off
i will take a couple questions before we
sign off
king's gambit is good
what do you think this no openings until
you are x comes from that's a great
question so where does it come from
yes no no no so where it comes from in
my take
is is that
i think that coaches have a
well-intentioned fear and a well-founded
fear
that somebody will try to memorize their
way to chess mastery
or that somebody will try to read an
entire opening book rated 700
and you know kill their early chess
development and kill their love for the
game
having tried you know trying to memorize
everything but i think that just like
now the abundance of resources
nobody's really going to try to do that
and some memorization is fine
i think that it should be made clear
that you shouldn't try to memorize
entire reams of opening theory unless
they're you know
wesley saw um or a gm
but a little bit of memory memorization
is a bit of a taboo thing and chess like
you
you know it's okay to attempt to
memorize the main lines you have to
memorize the main lines
right of any opening that you play
because that
frees up space for our actual
understanding
right let's see
i'm not sure uh of course what you mean
by that
let me see book argument
so closed positions i'm pretty sure
there's um
there are some chess.com courses but
i'll think questions about books and
material i'll think about separately
let's see
how do we push it to that again that's a
very general question i can't
condense that no losing counseling
rights is definitely not quite that bad
if your queens are off the board but
it's not great
yeah so the french okay guys so let me
address the french for a second because
i know
people are really curious about it
um the french is i would
say probably a b tier opening in terms
of its objective value
so actually white has not found
an advantage against the french
objectively
but in order to maintain in order to
play well black caster
on black has to know insane amounts of
dangerous lines and white has found many
many ways
to put pressure on the french um and so
it's not objectively speaking it's not
necessarily worse than the nadar for the
karo khan
but from a practical perspective even
for grand masters
playing the french is very dangerous
because uh also potentially very
rewarding
it unbalances the position but you have
to be
tremendously well versed in a
just you know massive amount of
dangerous lines if that makes sense but
it's not terrible no no grandmaster
worth herself would ever say that
and people who joke about it joke about
it for that reason because black loses a
lot of quick games even grand masters
because if you forget a single move you
just get crushed and the night off is
the same way but not quite
right um
atarash is fine for beginners i
recommend the advanced variation for
beginners because it teaches you
how to play uh with better central
control and good piece development
in the last game can you talk a little
bit more about knowing when to wait and
when to pull
the trigger on those captures you can
wait on can you can you give me a
specific oh like this
yeah so so this is a bit of a um
technicality because there's nothing
wrong with taking immediately
but the logic here is am i in a hurry to
take on f8
is can he avoid this if i don't do it
right and the answer is no like there's
nothing black can do in this position
to disallow the option of queen takes f8
on the next move
so in order to preserve flexibility
because maybe
i will want to not trade because maybe
he'll do something
like queenie five or queen e6 right and
then i take with checkmate so
it's all about flexibility being able
to deviate as much as possible when
you're up a rook it's purely academic
it doesn't matter but i'm still trying
to illustrate the sort of thought
processes here if that makes sense andy
star thank you for the uh tier one
all right um well bishop h6 sets up a
bunch of trades
all right guys let's pause here for
today
i will be back tomorrow and i will be
back tomorrow
let's see what let me check my calendar
i will be back probably in the morning
actually tomorrow
yeah i'll be back in the morning guys
um somewhere around 11 a.m
uh eastern time i'll be back somewhere
around 11 a.m eastern time for coffee
blitz
and good times i hope you guys enjoyed
the speed run and the blitz i played so
much better over the past couple days
i'm really happy
even though i lost a couple games to end
but still um this was a longer stream
than i expected i'm gonna head to bed
guys thank you so much everybody for
all of the support it's always a
pleasure truly
thank you proffer thank you everybody i
greatly appreciate greatly appreciate
this community